- magic somewhere in the ancient mystic
Trinity you get three forget what
Schoolhouse Rock taught you kids for the
magic number at least in Borderlands the
handsome collection it is the long long
forgery of the Borderlands franchise
four players on one television has
finally been realized count 1 2 3 4
players playing Borderlands 2 4 players
playing Borderlands the pre-sequel
they're both on the same disc because
that's how the handsome collection rolls
if you don't know now yet no this is all
on the PlayStation 4 but you can also
four player size on the Xbox one because
it's 2015 and this is the future we were
promised by our ancestors so that
handsome collection has four players
foot screen yes
it follows that three player and two
player split-screen are also possible as
is up to 4 players online style
basically anything you could do then you
can do now including playing with your
existing character you can transfer your
Borderlands 2 or pre sequel saves from
the Xbox 360 the Xbox one and then just
sign in on whatever Xbox one you want to
play on and your Krieg will be in the
cloud new enemy idea psycho clouds
we're welcome gearbox on the PlayStation
4 or the PlayStation 3 or the
PlayStation Vita you've got cross save
baby Borderlands 2 in your home or on
the go same character different
platforms
the pre-sequel has cross safe - just
that there's no Vita version so it's
mostly just in your home or your
friend's home or like your local library
if they're super cool and have a video
game night which they should hey you
know what else this games got all the
DLC you know how much DLC they made for
Borderlands 2 this much for campaign
add-ons - new vault hunters bunch of
headhunter packs few level increases and
a metric ton of character customization
packs the pre-sequel DLC is in there -
all the stuff that the season pass
holders got you get for $59.99 on March
25 Borderlands the handsome collection
saucy
[Music]
you